another thing dr bride is not allowed to  do with the foundation dr bright is not  allowed to kick scp-2558-j  scp-2558-j refers to a group of  seemingly ordinary kittens who display  friendly and affectionate behavior  towards humans and each other when  startled or made to feel afraid the  kittens inflate into a fluffy spherical  shape about the size of a soccer ball  able to move around by rolling dr bright  is not permitted to kick any of the  kittens whether they are in ball form or  not he is also strictly prohibited from  playing dodgeball volleyball or any ball  based game with scp-2558-j  the only way anyone is permitted to play  with the kittens is using the  foundation-sanctioned cat toys provided  upon request for crying out loud man  they're kittens